Alabama congressman Gary Parma was only
about 20 yards away from the shooter he
joins us now from the Capitol
congressman Palmer good morning
Warren Charlie set the situation where
you were what you heard what you saw and
what you believe was going on we were
taking batting practice and I was at
shortstop Steve Scalise was at second
base and Frank Kelly was at third and
when I heard the gunshot I knew
immediately what it was and I yelled at
Trent that was a gunshot
and Tran said yeah turn in and yelled
he's got a gun
the guy was coming up to the fence I
think when you fire the first shot he
was a little bit back and frankly it's a
miracle that he missed transplants a big
guy we moved across the baseball game
too important that you have first base
side that for the only open gate in
defense was and I heard two more shots
and I saw Scalise go down I knew had
been hit I knew he'd been hit a low and
but I didn't know what's in the hip or
the leg Carson we are all trying to
process what happened yesterday I think
many people are still reeling from it
and now come reports that it might have
been politically motivated this man
apparently was unhappy with the
Republican Party and its many
disparaging things what do you think
when you hear about that what needs to
happen based on the conversation that is
happening in the country right now I
think our our Republic's in danger Gail
I think we're praying at the edges
there's extremes on both sides and I've
been hearing some of the reports of what
this gentleman had posted on his
Facebook page and it's not that
different from some of the things that
we're hearing from other people so we've
got to tone down the rhetoric I think it
has to begin with us both both parties
but it's got to come from the media it's
got to come from other people who are
speaking to the country and and
particularly in the social media
congressman is I mean is that worse
that's a pretty serious thing to say the
Republic is in danger and that the
country is fraying at the edges I mean
is is that you you think it starts in
Washington though does it start with
social media where do where does what
what concrete steps need to be taken in
your estimation well I think we've got
to lead by example obviously Republicans
and Democrats differ on issues but I
think we can have a civil discussion you
said that the Democrats at that playing
field were actually praying when they
heard about the shooting on the
Republican side Teddy Roosevelt used to
call the White House the bully pulpit do
we begin with leadership from the White
House in terms of trying to cool down
things and trying to create more
civility and trying to create a more
common ground well I think it begins
with me against with my colleagues I
think all of us have a stake in this and
everyone of us need to take
responsibility for what we say and how
we say it do you think that this will
lead to a different conversation about
gun control and guns in this country
your governor the governor said
yesterday a Virginian Terry McAuliffe we
should have that conversation now is not
the time I think many people thought
after Sandy Hook things would change and
unfortunately very little seems to have
changed well all I know is is first of
all the government all go to stats Rome
and again used to stat for the 93 gun
violence death a day that that's
inaccurate in the context that he was
using it
as a gun owner I can tell you I wish I'd
had one yesterday you wish you'd had a
gun yesterday so you could strike back I
would would would have liked have had a
firearm I think Craig Kelly would have
there a number of others would wish that
we had been able to defend ourselves and
come to the aid of the Capitol Police
who were extraordinary
- thank you for joining us thank you
Charlie